welcome to Washington I'm Bret Baier
breaking tonight we're just getting a
ruling in from a judge the former White
House Counsel Don McGann must comply
with a house subpoena
according to court rules our ruling just
in from a judge this is a lawsuit that
was filed by the House Judiciary
Committee now this court is compelling
the former White House Counsel Don
McCann to testify in the house this as
the impeachment process goes from the
House Intelligence Committee to the
House Judiciary Committee when lawmakers
come back as the House Judiciary
Committee will then be compelled to
essentially write articles of
impeachment chief White House
correspondent John Roberts has been
following this this federal judge with
this ruling compelling the former White
House Counsel to testify John joins us
live than North long could even jump to
you Brett it was a federal judge
cattaneo Brown Jackson who just ruled a
short time ago the Don Magan does have
to comply with a congressional subpoena
to testify in the impeachment process
now the reason why this is important is
because so far the president has said
that he and people who worked for him
have absolute immunity from testifying
before Congress and don't forget there
are other subpoenas that are out there
as well there's one to Mick Mulvaney
there is one to Charles Kupperman who is
the former deputy director of the
National Security Council
there could be one for John Bolton and
Kupperman has got another case that is
going to be heard on December the 10th
so if this judge's ruling that McGann
has to comply then potentially other
White House officials who have been
subpoenaed or may be subpoenaed may have
to comply as well as this thing goes to
the next phase now if McGann testifies
it's likely that he wouldn't know
anything about what happened with
Ukraine because McGann left a little bit
more than a year ago Pat Cipollone II is
the current White House Counsel who
would be read in on everything dealing
with Ukraine but do not forget the
McGann testified before Robert Muller in
the Robert Moeller Russia inquiry for
some 30 hours and has an awful lot of
information about what happened in
regard to
Russia and possible collusion and what
potential obstruction of justice Muller
was alluding to in his report so still a
lot more to come on the potential
fallout from again having to testify and
exactly who he will testify to now the
House and Senate are not in session this
week they are of course offer their
Thanksgiving recess but the House
Intelligence Committee is busy writing
up its report that it will submit to the
House Judiciary to see where this all
goes next for its part the White House
it went to the dogs today one very brave
four-footed special operator Conan came
over from the Middle East
visited Trump today introduced the
nation to Conan the Belgian Malinois
instrumental in the recent takedown of
Isis leader Abu Bakr al-baghdadi in a
fantastic Conan was seriously injured
while chasing Baghdadi into a tunnel and
he detonated his explosive vest the God
nearly electrocuted when hit by exposed
wire
President Trump also with impeachment on
his mind
tweeting today that support for
impeachment is dropping like a rock down
into the 20s in some polls it's unclear
where the president came up with that
number the five thirty eight.com average
has support for impeachment down three
points to forty five point six percent
while opposition has risen two points to
forty five point five percent sources
confirmed to Fox News that White House
Counsel Pat's Apollonia is looking at
internal communications regarding the
hold on aid to Ukraine some of the
discussion between acting chief of staff
Mick Mulvaney and the Office of
Management and Budget regarding the
legal aspects of impounding the funds
which may have required court action as
today president Trump said he continues
to have confidence in Mulvaney president
Trump also gave a big thumbs up to his
embattled attorney Rudy Giuliani and
broiled in controversy regarding his
involvement with Ukraine and indicted
associates love partner sandy gorf rumen
according to The Wall Street Journal
federal prosecutors have issued
subpoenas that suggest the investigation
into partisan Froman goes beyond
campaign finance violations to possible
money laundering and obstruction of
justice and the prosecutors may be
looking closely at the work of Giuliani
himself in the strongest mayor the best
Mayor Rudy is a great crime fighter I
think that maybe the press isn't
treating Rudy very well and I think
that's unfair and when Congress returns
from the Thanksgiving break the ranking
member of the House Intelligence
Committee plans to sue CNN and The Daily
Beast for reporting that he was working
with Ukrainian officials to try to dig
up dirt on Joe Biden congressman Devin
Nunez tells FOX News it is the fake news
story of the century
Nunez saying he will file two lawsuits
likely in federal court and just to get
back to where we started at the
beginning of all this and breaking news
a federal district judge ruling the dawn
began the former White House Counsel
comply with a congressional subpoena to
testify in the impeachment inquiry we
have not heard any reaction from the
White House since this ruling was issued
but I would say Brett it's a fair bet
the White House is going to take this to
the appeals court yeah the judge
finishes saying that mr. McGann is
legally required to testify he is
enjoined it says to appear before the
committee pursuant to the subpoena that
was issued to him by the House Judiciary
Committee April 22nd John thanks for
covering the breaking news tonight